NO AFT ICTURE OF HIM ED
OE S
"GETR  AFEFLOYD'
N MITCHELLOLD THPOS T HE
MBER WEARING
WASHINGTON.
HE DID NOT CONFIRM NORENY TH
ALR  NOW. TO
FIRST, DID YOUTICIPATE IN ANY OE
TRIOMARCHES
AGAINST POLICE BLIHA
OBVISLHINGTON.NGTO
HE AD NO W ALREADY
DESCRIBED ABOVE, HAV
YO TO YOICIPATED
OUF
OROLE
D --LIED N
.ARE HIS PROBLEAND
COULD THERE BEROORPE COULD BE G
APPEALMORE HAS TBE KNOWN WHA
CONCVET QUESTION AND EXACTLYO A
INCO T
MISTRIAL.BE
ABOUWH HAN HE
THE QUESTION BAU'RE INND
EN A PROTEST
AN IWASN'T ABOIT
S WA FE CAN MAKE OVERARCHINGCON.
ABOUGEORGE F. Ath
VEOF THE MCH O
WASHINGTON.
HERE, THOUGH
ANNOUNCING MNGN.LET'S LISTEN>
28thD RECOMMITTHAT DREAMD JUST
FIGHT SLAVERY,NO
ERA WE WITVOTINGL WITH
POLICING AND CMI
G THE  DE POLICING AND IM
JUSTICE.
BY THE WAY, HE ANNOUNC
GEORGE FLO'S FUNS FAMILY LEDY
STATE OF WHAT HEHERE A.GE IKINGE
PLE IN IT OR
Y WHAT HE THAT EVENT AND THAT DO
TUD
INTO CONSI TOTALITY ISOIO THINK
ABOUT WHAC
THWAS R,ED AND
ALTALKT LIKELY
LVNE THE
SAY, OKAY, WHAT ISHIJUROR'S VE
OIR HE HO DECIDEGIVES RISE TO TT
OR
ABOUT HIONSES ORBE HS EVEN UNTR
ONS JIR.
OUT WHAT'S GOING AS E T HEAR
WITHASE LIKE THIS AND
VERDICT THSONS
FAMILY, FOR A ORW
PREPARATIONS FOR POTENTIUNG
JURY OR  ACQUITTAL, IS THERE
ECIDING OR
DETERMININEFT AI AJURY?
>> T
FACTOR, NOT G FA
JUDGES ALL THE TDETERMIO THE
NCES.
NOW,URTHE DECISION
IST.NOT GOINWA T AS
DECISI BTS
FAIR AND IMPARALWAS APNEGHT TO
SOME OF THE S  QUESTIONNAI